today on the Matt wall show an elected
official in Tennessee labels me Ben
Shapiro and Candace Owens as members of
The Vortex of evil which incidentally is
also the name of the death metal band
we're forming meanwhile the outrage mob
descends again calling on Ben to fire me
because I dared to say that I don't want
my children to be indoctrinated into the
trans cult totally offensive stuff
apparently also Marjorie Taylor green
continues to advocate for her National
divorce plan James O'Keefe is officially
pushed out of the organization that he
founded and some conservative social
media have found their new hero a
cross-dressing makeup salesman who
advocates for transgenderism all of that
and more today on the Matt Walsh
[Applause]
[Music]
people are raving about genucel skin
care Jessica from Huntsville Alabama
says my skin looks so soft and clear
I've seen a reduced number of fine lines
and dark spots I found a new lifetime
product absolutely love it well genucel
was born from its founder in a small New
Jersey town as a favorite one of his
Pharmacy customers using rare Botanical
extracts and scientifically researched
ingredients genucel is uniquely
formulated to Target all visible signs
of aging Fine Lines wrinkles dark spots
a sagging jawline and even those puffy
under eye bags the genocell product you
use today uses the same one-of-a-kind
proprietary flower base developed by its
Founders All Those Years Ago all genu
cell products work for both men and
women plus they're safe for all skin
types you're guaranteed to see immediate
results in 12 hours or your money back
you know I've told you my talent manager
Tessa uses genucel under eye treatment
to help get rid of the bags under her
eyes we talk about all the time the skin
care regimen and it really works
trigenousel's most popular package for
70 off at genucel.com Welsh join
millions of happy customer who have
already fallen in love with the results
Plus for a limited time get genu sales
probiotic extract infused moisturize
moisturizer free with every most popular
package subscribe and get a
complimentary bonus box as well go to
genucel.com
walshenucell.com Walsh
one of these days perhaps I'll make it
through a 24 hour period without
provoking the outrage mob just as a
matter of mathematical odds it seems
certain that eventually I'll have a day
of peace and quiet but that day is not
this day apparently this day the mob is
very upset yet again and has me trending
on social media yet again trending right
alongside the also canceled on Jemima by
the way
um she's uh also I don't know why she's
trending but she is because of a segment
from yesterday's show and during the
daily cancellation yesterday if you
listen to the show you know I delivered
my final rebuttal to the conservatives
who have been relentlessly attacking me
for being as they claim to mean to trans
activists like Dylan Mulvaney well my PR
reps over Media Matters were of course
is always watching and listening
intently taking careful notes as they
always do and towards the end of the
monologue they found the bit they needed
for their headline emphasis on bits
because they only need a phrase right
not not even a full sentence because
they can write the rest of it themselves
they just need me to say like a couple
of words and then they'll do the rest
that's exactly what they did with this
headline
daily wire host I would rather be dead
than have a trans child that's the
headline and from there other Media
Matters goons like Arie Drennan ran with
it Airy tweeted in another unhinged rant
about Dylan Mulvaney Matt Walsh says
that he would rather die than allow his
kids to be trans Matt says he's entitled
to whatever language he wants as am I
his six kids are not safe with him and
he should not be allowed within a mile
of them
it's circulated from there to the
corporate media where NBC reporter and
obsessed fan Benjamin Ryan posted quote
Matt Walsh employs violent incendiary
rhetoric to stir up moral Panic against
transgender people as he proclaims he'd
rather die than have a trans child
and soon there are people uh tagging Ben
Shapiro and calling for me to be fired
uh because you know of course that's the
kind of thing that would happen here the
Delhi wire I would be fired for being uh
too aggressive in my
in my uh in my opposition to you know
transgenderism
one of those posts calling for me to be
fired earned a like from conservative
quote unquote Jonah Goldberg who is so
conservative that he thinks conservative
media figures should lose their jobs for
not wanting their children to be trans
that's that's conservative media now
of course the outrage mob uh made its
way outside of the walls of Twitter out
into Reddit and other forums and the
left-wing media World leading to
headlines like this from the leftist
internet rag Alternet a fate worse than
death Matt Walsh launched his vicious
attack on parenting trans kids
now at this point it might be relevant
to go back and listen to the comment
that these people are so upset about I
know that as far as the outrage mob is
concerned there's no need to consider
what a person actually said when
deciding whether to be angry about what
they said all that matters is how they
feel about what they think I said
be that as it may for those who care
about irrelevant details like you know
the truth
well here's the clip
I have personally heard from many
parents
more than I can count
who tell me versions of the same Horror
Story
a beautiful and innocent kid one day
seemingly out of nowhere gets sucked
into the gender occult and is devoured
by it
the child they held as a baby and raised
and gave their lives to and loved and
still loved
become suddenly unrecognizable
all of their innocence and light and
Beauty just drained out of them replaced
by this self-cannibalizing madness
for a parent to see this happen to a
child it is a fate worse than death I
would rather be dead than have that
happen to my kids
see the thing that I most despise about
Dylan Mulvaney is that he is part of a
movement which actively seeks to turn my
children into Dylan Mulvaney
that's why I'm entitled to my anger and
to whatever language I use to convey it
I will say whatever I want to say and I
will be justified in saying it because
these people are after my kids
and yours
and everyone else's
and you're worried that I'm being a
little rude
well you see when it comes to my
children
the children that I cherish more than my
own life
if you think mean words go too far
then you would be very shocked to hear
how far I would really go to protect
them
trust me words are the least of it
okay so there it is that's that's the
clip that Media Matters posted
um I know you don't need me to say this
because at this point it certainly goes
without saying but I obviously stand by
all that I'm happy that I said what I
said I'm happy with the way that I said
it and um I don't care if it hurt your
feelings
uh you know this is not one of those
well I'm sorry if I hurt your feelings
I'm not sorry I've hurt your feelings
like I'm glad that it did because from
what I've seen the people who've had
their feelings hurt by this deserve to
have their feelings hurt so I'm glad
that it makes you uncomfortable I really
am
my point was very clear
um
I love my kids I would give my life to
protect them I jump in front of a moving
train if they were stuck on the tracks I
would dive in front of a bullet this is
what me it means to be a loving parent
and any loving parent feels the same way
about their own kids that means that I
would also if necessary uh give my life
to stop my children from being
indoctrinated into a death cult that
will deprive them of their sense of
identity lead them towards
self-mutilation and self-harm and a
large percentage of cases lead to
suicide
obviously I'd rather die than have my
kids suffer such a fate I I have said
some provocative things in my time I've
offered up I'll admit some hot takes
that even I will confess were a bit on
the eccentric side even though I was
still right about all those but this is
not one of those takes this is very
normal I want my kids to be happy and
whole and fulfilled I want them to live
fruitful and productive lives I don't
want them to fall prey to a poisonous
social contagion that will deprive them
of all of that
such as that I don't want it it's that I
will fight to my dying breath to prevent
it this is not extremism it's love
and loving your child is normal or it
should be
this is how the game is played though
take a normal thing
try to make it unspeakable and
Unthinkable shrieking horror at what is
normal and healthy and virtuous and hope
that the shrieks alone are enough to
convince people to run the other way
it's an effective strategy to a certain
extent as anyone who understands group
psychology can tell you
you know you could try and experiment
walking down a busy sidewalk suddenly
look behind you and then run away with a
terrified expression on your face if you
do that it's guaranteed that other
people will run with you even though
they have no idea what you're running
from your reaction to the imaginary
threat was enough to convince them and
the left deploys this method at an
ideological level and on a culture-wide
scale
and here they do it again a Man simply
says that he doesn't want his children
to fall victim to a self-mutilating cult
the left hears this totally normal
sentiment and reacts as though that man
had advocated for genocide and they hope
that others will follow them in their
panic
no need to articulate any sort of
coherent argument against the statement
any more than you'd have to make an
argument to the crowd on the sidewalk in
order to convince them to run away from
the invisible monster
you know they don't have to explain why
normalcy is evil they just have to treat
it that way and hope that other people
will follow suit
speaking of which we're on the verge of
getting our law passed here in Tennessee
Banning the mutilation and castration of
children that's uh I'd expect that to
happen this week the state legislature
responded in a big way to uh my report
exposing Vanderbilt and now we will
ensure that the things that I uncovered
there will not happen ever again in this
state anywhere but not every Tennessee
legislator is on board with protecting
children we do have a few Democrats here
in this state sadly and as we saw at the
hearing a few weeks ago they are very
depressed about the fact that kids can't
be mutilated anymore they're very upset
about it
very down one of those legislators is
state representative Gloria Johnson who
is a particularly loathsome witch who
feels personally attacked by our efforts
to protect children she takes it very
personally
um and that's that's how it is you know
groomers take their grooming seriously
and they don't take kindly to those who
stand in the way
in fact Johnson has noticed that
Tennessee is becoming more conservative
as more and more sane and decent people
move here
you know we moved in and next thing you
know child castration and child drag
shows are about to be illegal
because apparently this state just ain't
big enough for all of us which means the
groomers and predators have to go that's
what led Johnson to tweet a few days ago
this
quote if I'm hearing this right the
following people now live in Tennessee
please correct me if I'm wrong
Betsy DeVos Rebecca Mercer Roger Stone
Tommy lahren Ben Shapiro Matt Walsh
Candice Owens who am I leaving out it
seems we are a testing ground for the
vortex of evil
now obviously it's not a healthy thing
for elected officials to label their own
constituents The Vortex of evil yeah
this is the kind of rhetoric that even
left this in government will use
they'll use it about their own
constituents and and they'll use it
while the right continues to debate
whether our own language is too harsh so
we're arguing amongst ourselves about I
don't know maybe we should be a little
bit nicer uh meanwhile they're out there
so you're the vortex of evil
you better not tell a man that he makes
an ugly woman that'd be very offensive
to the sorts of people who already
consider you to be a member of the
vortex of evil
that said I I have to say I'm honored by
the label you know I've been wondering
what our super villain Squad name should
be and now we have it I thought about
axis of Evil but that's already taken a
cyclone of evil might overdo it a little
bit Vortex of evil that's the one
mostly though I'm honored because I know
what they consider to be evil it's
always opposite day with these people so
the word evil simply means good
or sane or normal
that's what they hate most of all
we are not Heroes because we oppose
child abuse and want to protect our own
children from it you don't have to be
heroic for that
we're just normal
you might say a Vortex of normal is
maybe what we should be called
but I guess that doesn't have quite the
same ring to it
now let's get to our five headlines
you know with the economy these days
it's uh it's just a matter of survival
for a lot of people uh live and paycheck
to paycheck looking for help from
Washington DC it's never going to happen
and if you own a business the past few
years especially have been a bumpy ride
from coveted lockdowns to bite inflation
you could probably use a break and
Innovation refunds can help with that if
your business has five or more employees
and manage to survive covid well you
could be eligible to receive a payroll
tax rebate of up to twenty six thousand
dollars per employee through the
employee retention credit it's not a
loan there's no payback it is a refund
of your taxes go to getrefunds.com to
find out about it their team of tax
attorneys are highly trained in this
little-known payroll tax refund program
they've already returned one billion
dollars of businesses and they can help
you to they do all the work no charge up
front and they simply share a percentage
of the cash that they get for you
businesses of all types can qualify
including those who took PPP uh
non-profits even those that had increase
in sales still are qualifying for this
see if your business qualifies for ERC
assistance in about eight minutes but
you got to go to getrefunds.com click on
qualify me and answer a few questions
this payroll tax refund is only
available for a limited amount of time
don't miss out go to getrefunds.com
getrefunds.com
yeah Vortex is normal I kind of like the
more I think about it it sounds like the
most boring version of The Avengers ever
conceived
um and one other note about Gloria
Johnson she's a uh a former teacher but
also unfortunately she's illiterate and
those are two things that go hand in
hand a lot more often than you'd like to
think so she tweeted this as well if we
put the Tweet up is another tweet that
you put up on a couple days ago we have
that
okay here it is this is what she tweeted
now try to follow along
if you're going to claim that your bill
to Outlaw something a loud minority
don't agree with it then you probably
shouldn't say it isn't relevant that the
majority of tennesseans don't agree with
other things they pay for as taxpayers
you killed your own argument
well you killed some brain cells at
least with that let me let me just go
through this guy because I honestly I'm
not even trying to be funny I can't
understand what she's trying to say uh
this is an elected representative former
teacher
if you're going to claim that you're
built to Outlaw something a loud
minority don't agree with it
well already I that's not that doesn't
work I so we can't even move if you're
going to claim that you're built to
Outlaw something a loud minority don't
agree with it
then you probably shouldn't say it isn't
relevant that the majority of
tennesseans don't agree with other
things they pay for as taxpayers you
killed your own argument
so you've got a a couple of weird
sentence fragments stitched together
with a with an incoherent series of
double negatives and uh and that's what
and that's what she decided to put out
there in the world this makes Kamala
Harris seem articulate by comparison
this is the this is like the written
equivalent of a stroke I felt like I was
having a stroke while reading it
it it reads as though she wrote a normal
sentence and then ran it through some
kind of translation software I don't
know if she normally speaks Mandarin
Chinese she doesn't seem like the type
but maybe that would explain it she
actually speaks Mandarin and then and
then so she but so she has to filter
everything through Google Translate to
tweet and then and then that's how you
end up with this I don't know there are
a lot of theories people have but um
uh I guess the world will never know
exactly okay
I want to begin here Marjorie Taylor
green set off uh as we discussed
yesterday an eruption of outrage a
couple days ago by suggesting a national
divorce and she hasn't backed down from
it
um and here she is on Fox news last
night
defending the idea let's listen to what
she says in my life in my world I all of
my friends are regular Americans
everyone I talk to is is sick and tired
and fed up of being bullied by the left
abused by the left and disrespected by
the left and our ideas our policies our
ways of life have become so far apart
that it's just coming to that point and
the last thing I ever want to see in
America is a civil war no one wants that
at least everyone I know would never
want that but it's going that direction
and we have to do something about it
we're also a nation a crumbling Nation
We're a nation in distress our
government is in complete failure over
34 trillion dollars we are on the verge
of default and we have to do something
about that but that was the right and
the left that did that to the American
people on their own but the Democrats
never stop pushing their policies their
ideas and their culture on Republicans
and the right and we are so sick and
tired of it we are tired of our children
being taught ideas that ideologies in
school that we do not want our children
taught like gender Lies We do not want
our children being having their gender
change or transitioned we we can't even
have women's sports and privacy in our
bathrooms and women in prison can't even
have spaces ESG environmental social
governance has completely taken over
corporations and this is a huge policy
pressed on private businesses through
the government from Democrats if you're
a white male today in the financial
industry you can forget it you're a
dinosaur you're going extinct no one
should ever be hired by their skin color
or their gender or how they identify it
should only be about your character and
your ability to do the job
okay
so she's not wrong about a lot of that
and
like I said yesterday she you know she's
not wrong to bring up the idea of
national divorce necessarily people have
been talking about this idea for Years
anyway and we might as well bring it on
to the National stage
in theory I get it I understand in
theory
but I want to put up this uh this visual
to buttress the point that I was trying
to make yesterday about this because the
problem there's a few problems with
national divorce but but the first and
most insurmountable one is a problem of
geography and for a national divorce a
geographic problem is a fatal problem
because it's all about geography and you
can't really get around it so
let's put this up someone tweeted this
to me yesterday
um just to to kind of
again emphasize my point they say tough
to divide this up and then it's a red
and blue map and you see the
distribution of red and blue voters
so let's keep this up because how how do
you divide this up and I I could see a
couple of easy cases here uh Vermont is
entirely blue basically Massachusetts
Connecticut New England in general
though even in New England you know New
Hampshire and Maine have a lot of red
California is of course heavily blue
um
New Mexico but who gets Pennsylvania
okay who gets who gets Virginia
who gets North and South Carolina
and you go out west it's pretty clear
that conservatives get Wyoming and like
the 10 people who live there but then
you know jump down south who gets
Colorado
what about Texas
there just is no way to divvy this up
without without first facilitating a
mass migration in two different
directions by hundreds of millions of
people who are all choosing to leave
their homes or are leaving their homes
by force
and uh and and probably much of their
families too by the way
does it matter how you divide this up
how many people are going to end up in a
situation where now your family half of
your family's in a foreign country
so that's what you have to do yeah
hundreds of millions of people just and
I don't know where I don't know where
the dividing line is here it's not this
is definitely not a clear it's not a
North versus South thing anymore uh it's
not that it's it's not East West it what
is it
and however you divide it you're going
to have is that we're gonna have
hundreds of millions of people all at
once going into opposite directions
it'll never happen
um it just it it will not happen it it
won't so we could talk about in theory
and and would it be better if it did
those are I'm fine with having
conversations in theory and the abstract
but when it comes down to it I'm a
practical person and I and I prefer to
we could talk about abstractions all day
but let's bring it back to the Practical
real world and in the Practical real
world that just isn't happening okay
um and by the way
I thought about this also you take the
take the Northeast for example so it's
likely that however you separate this it
would mean that the left gets the
Northeast where I was born and raised
um but I'm not going to agree to that
okay that's that's my home that's where
I was born that's where my family lives
and that's also where so much of our
nation's history is
that's why I've always loved the
Northeast
and that's one of my ties to it still
and it's got a lot of problems
culturally and it is politically mostly
dominated by the left that's true
although in a place like Pennsylvania
it's like you know you take Philadelphia
out of it and you take Pittsburgh out of
it and this is a that's a conservative
State for the most part
but
but even even aside from all that it's
just it's got so much history so much of
our nation's history is there
and are you really willing to give up
most of the the most significant
historical landmarks and monuments and
locations are you really are you willing
to give that to the left and say you can
have give it over to people who are
going to desecrate and destroy it
are you willing to give that to them
to people who hate it
I'm not willing to do that I'm not just
going to give it to them oh you can have
all this all you know so much of our
nation's history you can have it
and do with what you will with it
hell no
so where does that leave us it means
that
what it means is that we have to fight
this out
okay that's what it means and we have to
win in the culture War
okay and it's not going to happen
overnight
as I'm always saying it's not it is not
an overnight solution and most of the uh
the kind of Doomer
perspective the uh the the people who
are fatalists about it and say that we
can never win it's impossible
they're talking about tomorrow okay and
and they are they're falling into
despair because they've noticed that we
can't win this fight by you know say
tomorrow around lunchtime and they're
right about that but this is a
generational struggle and you just have
to accept that
and for a long time most people
throughout the world This Is How They
Live they lived understanding that they
existed in One Moment In Time and but
they were just part of this this this
you know uh this chain where of
ancestors and then descendants and so
they lived and they wanted to build a
legacy and build a future for people uh
who would come after them their children
and grandchildren they they were worried
about what the world and what their
country and what their their culture
would look like when they were dead and
gone and weren't part of it anymore
but all we're worried about in the kind
of microwave age all we're worried about
is the immediate well we have to get
past that it's a generational struggle
and so there's no way to divide this up
instead
we're gonna have to have a lot of kids
and raise them well
and win this culture back in our country
back and our history back
over time
because I'm not willing to give it up
I'm not surrendering my home to these
people
I'm not giving our history over to them
I'm not giving the places where I was
born and raised
not giving the places where my family
lives
hell no
you know something else too I'm also not
giving up on the children who live
in the areas that would be you know part
of uh leftist stand or whatever they're
going to call it
I'm not I'm not going to give up on them
it's not their fault
so I win this fight to for example
protect kids from Child mutilation or
protect kids from being murdered in the
womb
you know it's one thing to say to adults
adult leftists that hey if this is the
if this is the country you want this is
what you want uh reap what you sow and
deal with it and I'm willing to say that
to them but I'm not willing to say to
their kids their kids didn't choose it's
not fair to them
I'm not going to consign all them to
this
either
so we're left with the fight what we're
left with get used to it
learn learn to love it
um
Pete bootage was tracked down by a
reporter yesterday and asked uh what
he's doing about the train derailment
situation and here's how that went
secretary what do you have to say Hi how
are you Jenny's here at the Daily Caller
news Foundation what do you have to say
to the folks in Ohio East Palestine who
are suffering right now blood or fruit
about a dozen interviews I've given
today and uh if you'd like to arrange a
conversation make sure to reach out to
the Press office
you don't have a message for them I do
and I shared it with the Press many
times today I'd refer you to those
comments would you mind sharing it with
us no I'm going to refer you to the
comments that I made to the Press
because right now I'm taking some
personal time and I'm walking down the
street are you going down there what's
up are you going down there at all
um yeah I am when are you going uh I'll
share that when I'm ready yeah
can I get a photo of you
you creep what was that why do you want
a photo of her
do I want to know
um he's taking some personal time you
know people to judge one thing we know
about this guy is that he loves his
personal time that's why he took six
months for maternity leave and now he's
taking some he's taking some personal
time did he actually say take us a
personal time to walk town to walk down
the sidewalk yeah take us a personal
time on this sidewalk here
you know what I want to hear from
Republican presidential candidates is um
what I really want to hear I want to
hear a lot from them but one thing I
want to hear is a serious proposal a
serious proposal
to gut these agencies like the
transportation department and abolish
most of them
like the transportation department
because that's one of the things that
we've learned from all this
which many of us already knew
which is that the you know an organ
agency like transportation department is
totally useless
and he's basically admitted it and in
all the interviews that he's given and
the reason you want to talk to the Daily
Caller is because he knew that he might
actually be pressed and he would face
some actual scrutiny so he's only going
to give interviews
what he's actually saying there is oh no
I don't want to talk to you you're going
to ask me actual questions sorry I I
only talked to Media I only talked to
reporters who don't ask me real
questions
oh dude are you gonna just say things
that set me up to go on a stump speech
oh you're not well then I oh yeah I'm in
it's personal time right now
but if you listen to the uh stump
speeches that he's been giving
they all really boil down to this isn't
my fault this isn't the purview of the
transportation department this is other
agencies and it's just a bunch of a
bunch of cya making excuses
and so I think that we should uh listen
to that take him at his word and say
well okay I guess the transportation
department is totally useless which we
always knew that it was
because if there could be trains
derailing this is the transportation
department and if there could be trains
derailing all over the country and
dumping toxic chemicals into the water
supply and not and on top of that we
also have flights being grounded because
the computer systems don't work and all
the rest of it and there's a chaos at
the ports in the supply chain
all that's happening and it's not the
fault of the transportation department
what that tells us is that the
transportation department does nothing
we have to imagine what if the
transportation department didn't exist
for the last two years would any of this
look any different
would it be worse somehow I mean could
it get worse
if it looks different at all it would
look different in the other direction
maybe some of this would be better
because you cut out some of the
bureaucracy that it interferes with
everything
okay bureaucracy gets in the way of
everything including keeping the trains
on the tracks
so we just need to get rid of it and
that's what I want to hear from
Republican presidential candidates what
I don't want to hear is like what we
heard from Larry Hogan yesterday uh a
platitude about I'm a small government
conservative I've heard enough of that I
don't don't call yourself small
government I don't need to hear it
what I want to hear is what are you
actually going to do and you need to go
in and start gutting these departments
and firing people and shutting down
agencies
no Republican president has done that
yet at least not in recent history
instead what they've done is expanded it
so we need promises on the record of
this department this department this
department are gone when I become
president
we can start a transportation department
we can move over to the education
department we uh you know and we can
continue for that I think we should
start with those two and continue from
there
Health and Human Services
uh so start with those three it's a long
list so we got to start somewhere
Delhi wire has this uh Vivek ramaswamy
the CEO of anti-wolf incorporators
running as a Republican president of the
United States in 2024 speaking of
Republican presidential candidates the
millionaire investor and author
announced the official start of his
campaign during appearance on Fox News
as Tucker Carlson tonight ramaswami's
announcement follows weeks of rumors and
reporting that he was considering a 2024
bid one thing I'll say about Rama Swami
is that I appreciate that his name looks
um daunting at first but then you
realize it's actually easy to pronounce
and for me as you know it's a very
important detail here
um so he announces uh he announced that
he's he's running for president he's 37
years old by the way it's just one of
the younger presidential candidates
we've had and he put out this ad
yesterday we'll watch a little bit of
the ad
we're in the middle of a national
identity crisis
Faith patriotism and hard work have
disappeared
only to be replaced by new secular
religions like covetism climatism and
gender ideology
we hunger to be part of something bigger
than ourselves yet we cannot even answer
the question of what it means to be an
American
today the woke left preys on that vacuum
they tell you that your race your gender
and your sexual orientation govern who
you are what you can achieve and what
you're allowed to think
this is psychological slavery and that
has created a new Culture of Fear in our
country that has completely replaced our
culture of free speech in America
and that is why today I am announcing my
run for president of the United States
this isn't just a political campaign
this is a cultural movement to create a
new American Dream for the Next
Generation
to me the American dream means you
believe in Merit that you get ahead in
this country not on the color of your
skin but on the content of your
character and your contributions
it means okay so that's a little bit of
uh that's a little bit of that ad and he
also as like I said in the article you
want to appear on on Tucker Carlson I
actually found him I I wasn't really
familiar with it with him before he
announced his run for president
um
I thought it'd be an effective
communicator and I agree with uh a lot
of what he says
um he has made getting rid of
affirmative action policies one of the
central parts of his campaign which
which I agree is very important
um
but he's also not going to win right and
he's just not so
as we've already discussed I'm I believe
in being practical we could talk in the
abstract but but it must come back down
to the Practical real world and in the
Practical real world he's not going to
win
um and I think he knows that
but I really have to wonder if failed
presidential campaigns are the best use
of effective communicators
now I'm not naive I know why they do it
they do it to you know increase their
own personal brand and visibility they
do it uh as a way of auditioning for a
cabinet spot you know so things like
that maybe one they want to get on the
ticket there are reasons why people
jump into a presidential race even
though they know they're not going to
win
but
um those might be the reasons
but I don't see them as especially good
reasons
and I really wish that uh people who are
effective communicators on the
conservative side and have good ideas as
he does
um I just don't I don't think it's the
best use of that talent to jump into a
failed presidential campaign especially
these days in the internet age of cable
news and everything and you go into the
presidential race so you just you're
gonna get ripped to shreds it's
guaranteed uh part of that is politics
but
I just wonder if if you risk damaging
yourself
more than you help yourself in the long
run by doing this
all right
something else I wanted to note here we
didn't get a chance to talk about this
yesterday but we've been following this
story a little bit this daily wire
reports James O'Keefe announced a break
with broad project Veritas the
investigative group you founded while
hinting at a new journalism Venture in
the future in a video posted to uh Vimeo
on Monday O'Keefe said he was stripped
of all decision making last week and he
described some clashes with leadership
O'Keefe was standing in a project
Veritas office said he has he was
relieved of his authority as CEO for at
least 180 days and removed from the
project Veritas board of directors
citing board meeting notes currently I
have no job at project Veritas he added
I have no position here based upon what
the board has done so I'm announcing to
you all today on President's Day that
I'm packing up my personal belongings
here
um and he's leaving now the project
Veritas board put out a statement where
they lay out the alleged malfeasance
that led them to suspend James O'Keefe
and force them out of the organization
keep in mind that a couple weeks ago on
social media the project Veritas they
they said they claimed that James he was
on vacation so they've already lied they
lied about it a couple weeks ago when
the reports first surfaced that he was
being pushed out and they said oh just
on vacation everything's fine so they
lied so we know that
but here's what they said in their
statement
here are a few examples of what has been
done what has been uncovered so far by
the project Veritas leadership this is
far from an exhaustive list
it is merely a small representative
sample this is their statement
fourteen thousand dollars on a charter
flight to meet someone to fix his boat
under the guise of meeting with a donor
sixty thousand dollars in losses by
putting together dance events such as
project Veritas experience
over a hundred fifty thousand dollars in
black cars in the last 18 months
thousands of dollars spent on DJ and
other equipment for personal use
hundreds of other acts of personal
injurement
um the board wants to work things out
with James and has tried every route
possible to remedy the issues at hand
and begin to take the legally required
corrective actions James has left us no
choice but to suspend him so on and so
forth
now this is this is bizarre we when we
first heard about this I I said at the
time that
like so many other people to me James
O'Keefe is Project Veritas you cannot
separate the two
um and from the very beginning this
smelled to me like a coup to push push
him out by people who have a grudge
against him people who have egos or
whatever else and they want to get rid
of them and clear them out and take over
and now that we have their statement
where they lay out their case and this
might not be everything we don't know
everything
but uh we don't know everything went on
behind behind the scenes but it's been
100 confirmed that number one that
project Veritas lied to the public a
couple weeks ago and now they're
presenting their case it may not be the
full case but this is what they're
choosing to lead with so we can assume
that uh if they had if they had you know
more if they had more shocking skeletons
in the closet they were going to drag
out they'd start with that
so this is the most shocking thing they
can do they can tell us about
and what they tell us is that he wasted
some money on a dance party and on some
Transportation expenses
I mean first of all
most of that including the dance party
can easily be justified as a valid
business expense if you're in the
organization you might not agree with it
you might not think it's a it's a good
way to to you know it's it's a it's a
it's a
a useful business expense but it is a
business expense
you know getting uh getting car services
for example obviously a business expense
150 000 whatever they said it was may
sound like a lot
but um those kinds of car services are
expensive and when you're traveling a
lot like uh James O'Keefe does it adds
up quickly so it's actually not that
shocking
the thing about getting the boat fixed I
mean um
maybe you can't justify that as a valid
business expense but is that all you
have really that's all you got
and for that you force out the founder
and face of your organization provoking
a mass Exodus of donors and supporters
probably taking your whole organization
down in the process and severing ties
with one of the most Visionary and
effective leaders in the movement
for that because he got his boat fixed
that's the reason
and why if you if this is not a coup
with people trying to take over the
organization that he founded and and uh
that that rests upon his work they use
the face the organization he's there
he's their primary fundraiser and
everything else if it's not a coup
against him
and you really have a problem with how
the money is being spent then why
wouldn't the board just resign and
protest
and say we can't be a part of it we
can't be a part of this uh organization
with money being spent on fixing boats
we can't do that fourteen thousand
dollars that says too much
if it's not a coup that's that seems
like that's what you would do but that's
not what they did instead they said
we're going to take over and kick you
out even though this is the organization
that you founded
I said this when I we first heard about
the the whole James O'Keefe
um controversy
I have no trouble believing that James
O'Keefe maybe rubbed some people the
wrong way
because he's highly effective and uh
he's a great mind and talent and people
like that tend sometimes to be difficult
in person that's not my experience with
with James I haven't you know I've only
met him a couple times seemed like a
nice guy to me
but it wouldn't my point is it wouldn't
shock me if it was the case
because highly effective and uh leaders
people who are great talents like they
they can sometimes be difficult they
make enemies that way people hold
grudges against them so what
you deal with it because that's the
price of having a guy like that leading
your organization it's a price worth
paying
and this is a trend on the right that
concerns me um I saw some people making
this point uh you know a few nights ago
that it seems like conservatives have
this tendency to turn against the most
effective and Brilliant and creative
people in their movement
like the greatest sin you can commit is
to be actually successful and effective
and the moment you do that well of
course you're gonna have a left coming
at you but your own people turn against
you because they're because they're
motivated by Envy whatever it is they
feel threatened by your success
I see this a lot the best people get
driven out driven away leaving us with a
bunch of bland mediocre bores
Ben Dominic of the uh Federalists made
this point last night I tend to disagree
with him on um significant you know a
number of issues but I think he I think
he had this right he said James O'Keefe
out at project Veritas is yet another
example of how right media in a donor
class have a deep intolerance for
creative genius
if Andrew Breitbart had lived they'd
have found a way to ditch him too
conservative media is a wash with medium
Talent who pay their bills on
forgettable churn that changes nothing
and has a half-life measured in hours
creatives rise up make a lot of noise
get a lot of enemies then get taken out
by their own then donors turn to the
mids
I think it's exactly right and I think
that's precisely what's happening with
James O'Keefe
which is why I along with many other
people most people from what I've seen
you know off wherever I'll be supporting
whatever organization he goes and and
and starts from here
um one other quick thing before we get
to the comment section we see these
moments go viral like once a month now
this is another Wheel of Fortune fail
which are always fun so we'll we'll
watch this video but if you if you're
just listening to the audio what you
should know is that this puzzle is
already solved except for one letter
and uh the letter the answer is fresh
tropical fruit
all the letters are there except for the
s in fresh
and here's what happens
yes there is an age
uh
uh solve it or spin it or but do
something quickly okay
what letter for you I'll go with a
G
uh Juliana it's your turn I'd like to
solve the puzzle yeah fresh tropical
fruit yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
you know when that happens and you're
sitting at home you're saying how in the
world connect but you know sometimes
it's a word that just doesn't want to
come into Focus for you it did for you
and in addition to that 650 we're
sending you to the island of Antigua
Elizabeth
you know one of the Sounds in this there
are some sounds in life that are uh
always going to be horrifying and the
last sounds that you want to hear uh
like the sound of a crunching metal when
you're driving a car you know it's just
one of those sounds and if you've been
in a car actually you remember that
sound forever uh another of those sounds
is if you're on a game show and you hear
a gasp of horror from the audience
that's you never want to you never want
to hear that now you can hear the
audience go what
um although I do have to say you know I
do love frag tropical fruit I go all the
time to the grocery store and I say Hey
where's your frag fruit at
but this is why here's the point I want
to make about this it is it's important
but it's not important at all but still
uh I think the internet age
makes it not worth it to go on Wheel of
Fortune and I don't I don't say this to
just wait look I'm a fan of Wheel of
Fortune in Jeopardy
um like anybody else but it's it's just
it's I would never go on any shows
anymore and I say that as someone who
look I watch Jeopardy and I will kill
that show I I will absolutely kill it
when I'm sitting there in uh my best
games on Jeopardy are when I'm totally
alone in the living room and no one is
there to hear me answering the questions
correctly
um and then I'll have to go tell my wife
about it and she won't care at all but
and I I've thought to myself and maybe I
should go and he said but it's just it's
not worth it because if you have a brain
fart moment okay you have a moment where
just like you have a total lapse and you
draw a blank and you you know you a
moment like that will now live in infamy
forever you it will be it will follow
you so that this poor woman for the rest
of her life she's gonna have that moment
so that's what you risk
that's the risk the risk is that you
have a terribly stupid moment and it
haunts you forever because of the
internet
um that's the risk that's the worst case
scenario what's best case scenario
best case scenarios that you win you
know twelve thousand dollars and a trip
to Cancun or something
it's not bad to win that but I don't
know if it's worth the risk
that's the point okay let's get to the
comment section
they're the sweet baby games
[Music]
well as you can see I have with me here
the answers to all of your problems the
Johnny The Walrus book bundle complete
with my magnum opus uh Johnny The Walrus
best-selling LGBT children's book Johnny
wallers and it's a also it's cuddly Tusk
companion proudly emblazoned with his
pronouns all of this is here to spread
joy and Sanity to all those plagued by
the greatest ills of our time you know I
get attacked so much for being mean and
all that that it's it's easy to forget
that I am actually the world's most
renowned LGBT children's author how
could you say such make such accusations
against someone like me right now you
can get this bundle at its lowest price
ever thanks to our the our president is
for sale sale over at dailywire.com shop
you can enjoy 40 off uh select daily
wire merchandise including the uh uh all
the things that I just mentioned the
sale ends on Friday so don't wait take
advantage of the deal while it lasts go
to thedailywire.com shop today
Amy Goodman says considering all the
threats Matt gets that are directed at
his family I don't think his anger is
irrational he's a father he's standing
up to protect children his yours and
mine we need his voice yeah well I would
I mean Amy I would feel this way uh
without the threats but it's also true
I think that a lot of the nicer
conservative types
um you know the conservatives that are
all about being nice and all that
I don't think they've ever fully
encountered the deranged demonic evil of
um trans activists in particular
and uh but I have and I've told you in
Broad Strokes about some of the threats
that I get
but I can't even tell you I can't tell
you everything they've done to threaten
my family and my wife and my children at
many of these things we have to deal
with are just better dealt with
privately for a whole host of reasons
but
um so that's all I can say
but yes I I have
I have seen these people for what they
really are
um and I don't think you need the
threats and all the rest of it to see it
but
when you have that stuff as well it just
becomes very clear the level of evil
that you are dealing with and I think
for for some of these nice conservative
types they just they've never
encountered that they never have
um and I also think it is interesting
note that you know we play that Montage
yesterday of some of the right of Center
uh commentators and YouTubers and stuff
that were um calling me mean and I I
think I don't know this for sure but
certainly most of them don't have kids
most of the people that were in that
Montage don't have kids uh maybe one or
two of them do but most of them don't
have kids and I'm willing to bet
that of the conservatives who are that
well we have to be nice you know those
types I I'm willing to bet that the
majority of them don't have children and
so they just they don't have the same
stake in this they don't have the same
skin in the game
and they they haven't really had to
think about you know like my God what if
my children were to fall victim to this
and when when that Prospect is put in
front of you in a very real way it just
changes things it makes you take this
much more seriously than I think some of
these people are taking it
um it makes you know it is it makes it
so that it's not just
it's not just a topic for YouTube okay
and I think for some of these people
and like I said I have no
personal grudge against any of them
uh most of them I like and I enjoy their
content
but
I think for some of them they they see
this it's just a topic it is a topic to
discuss on on YouTube or on Twitter or
whatever
but for some of us it is not only that
it's a lot more than that it's a lot
more real than that to us
uh
Lana says as a stay-at-home mom a job
that I absolutely love who rarely has
adult interactions outside of my husband
in church I often feel voiceless and
helpless in these increasingly depraved
and disgusting world thank you from the
bottom of my heart for using your
platform to speak the truth by the way
I love these people saying you're too
harsh to read the Apostle Paul's letters
and tell me that he killed them with
kindness
but not just the Apostle Paul I mean
yeah the Apostle Paul is prime example
this was someone who
was very blunt in his approach and
what would also use actual insults I
know that people that don't actually
read the Bible but but are you know
familiar with it by reputation
especially the gospels and uh and with
the New Testament and the Epistles
no people like that
to to to suggest that there are Saints
in the Bible who actually insult people
you know to them it's kids well that
couldn't have happened no well it did uh
pick it up and read it sometime read the
language that they used but not only the
Apostle Paul Jesus Christ as well
okay and some of the stuff we we've
heard it so many times we've taken for
granted but a statement like
you'd be better drowning in the ocean
with a stone tied around your neck than
doing what you're doing
that's what Jesus said that's what Jesus
said about people that harm children
and and Lead children into into Scandal
into sin
um
that's what he said now imagine for a
second that Jesus hadn't said that
but then someone else said you know like
what what if what if what if uh just
what if I said it what if I said that
what if that's what I said about Dylan
Mulvaney
you know you'd be better off drowning in
the ocean with a stone tied around your
neck
um
you'd have a lot of conservatives and
Christians that would hear that so
that's the most I can't believe you
would say it's the worst thing anyone's
ever said this is horrible who would
ever say this is evil you're a fake
Christian
well that's what Jesus said that's what
he said
and in fact uh Jesus go again read the
gospels read them
and what you're going to find is that he
he had no tolerance for for evil none
and he would tell people very bluntly to
their face
and he would describe their actions in
very harsh terms this was not like one
we only have
comparatively we are only given
comparatively few episodes from Jesus
Christ's life
um and and of course we know that that
you know the the the
Lion's Share of it is we were told
nothing about it all
so we have when he was born and then we
have one brief episode from adolescence
and then we have
um and then we have adulthood
a a brief really brief episode of
adulthood
and even in that and even that in that
snapshot
we have Jesus flipping tables in the
temple using actual violence remember it
says he Fashions a chord out of whips
it wasn't even like he grabbed he took
some time it sounds like to make a whip
and then use it against people
said you're better off driving with
stone around your neck calling people
Hypocrites and Vipers and all these
kinds of uh words
and that's just in the parts that we're
told about
so I'm sorry the uh the hippie Jesus
thing is just it's a modern invention
it's not real
um
and finally Joe says you've really been
handing out some excellent cancellations
lately Matt today was perfect the
Chelsea Handler one was great too so
great in fact that while driving alone
in my car I actually shouted boom shots
fired captain in a Scottish accent it
was more of a pirate accident
considering the captain reference either
way you're inspiring your deck mates or
I should say mateys to loot more and
more sweet treasure from the woke
culture and to shout in random and in
discernible Accents in their cars well
Joe I'm uh I'm I'm just glad to find out
that I'm not the only one who tries out
different accents while alone in my car
so maybe I'm not as psychotic
as I thought or I still am but I'm not
alone in that the daily wire is seeking
our first ever vice president of social
media to join our team in Nashville
Tennessee this person will oversee a
large team that teaches uh that reaches
rather and teaches maybe 95 million plus
viewers across our social platforms uh
this leader will serve as our social and
content strategy lead to help us
continue scaling our pages and platforms
across YouTube Instagram Facebook snap
and uh much more this is the perfect
role for someone who loves to roll up
their sleeves and work alongside their
team as well as someone who can think
strategically about the content that we
put on social media for more information
and to apply go to dailywire.com Walsh
and click careers that's dailywire.com
Walsh today now let's get to our daily
cancellation
thank you
today for our daily cancellation I must
again unfortunately cancel people on my
own side or at least theoretically on my
own side um these are the conservatives
who over the past few days
have been frantically applauding their
latest hero their newly elected
spokesman their trendiest new
conservative Champion Jeffrey Starr and
for those unfamiliar as I was until two
days ago star is a social media
influencer and owner of a popular I
think Cosmetics brand uh star also
enjoys dressing like a woman
but this flamboyant cross-dressing
makeup salesman earned Applause from any
on the right including prominent figures
on the right
when he appeared on a podcast and said
this
I might even tell all the other I think
what other Vive in them yeah and all
that extra that we added during the
pandemics everyone was so bored on their
houses they just started to make up more
more stuff yeah that's where the
conservatives like me because I'm just
real yeah you do have a conservative to
them you're trans you're male or your
female and you're standing on that so
mad when I say that how are you with
they what the does that mean it's
stupid is what it is yeah but you need
someone like me that looks like me to
say it because if you say it it turns
into your homophobic you hate trans
people you hate gays and it's just how
you feel you don't hate anyone you just
think it's stupid
now that what you just heard makes
Jeffree Star based apparently he's based
now he said one thing that conservatives
like and they were on the scene with
pom-poms in no time and yes star is
right that the they them stuff is BS of
course
obviously but the problem one of them
anyway is that he rejects non-binary
while affirming trans he says that the
only valid categories are trans male or
female
and to drive that point home he made
another video responding to the backlash
against his anti-vay them commentary
where he reiterated his support for and
belief in transgenderism here it is
I just went on and I saw a few Outlets
saying that I'm transphobic Jeffree Star
who has five transgender employees
I have over 100 employees of all
different ethnicities
a brand that is inclusive to the entire
world what we're not going to do is lie
so if you posted an article saying
anything like that you better delete it
Miss thing because I'm coming
all I said was I don't agree with
pronouns that's it
so you know how cardi B's to that woman
and Well the lady don't have any money
but Card review won allegedly a lot of
money from the lawsuit even though
she'll never get it it's still the point
of she won that was phenomenal for
someone like me that has been abused and
dragged through the mud now we all know
all my past mistakes girl every time
that I have an opinion everyone has to
bring up everything from the past
it's that's getting so old but the
support and the understanding and the
common sense for millions of people that
I've seen over the last few days it made
it made me realize I'm the planet's not
that awful like people get it it's just
social media and they love to drag Miss
Jeffrey Lynn
also shout out to so many amazing
beautiful transgender people and the
LGBT community in my DMs writing me
um just thank you
this is I'm sorry about that this is
just too much between between this guy
and the uh Gloria Johnson tweet it's
just
the amount of brain cells we're losing
it's really it's like the effect of a of
a concussion we're all now concussed
effectively because of the level of
stupidity that we've been been forced
well that I have forced you to
encounter today
um but very inspiring response from this
right-wing Warrior who desperately
defends himself from the transphobia
claims by bragging about all the trans
people he employs
I suppose it just goes to show that uh
Democrats really are the real
transphobes of course check back in
about five years and people on the right
will be defending transgenderism and
non-binary but then claiming that uh
trans speciesism is where they draw the
line and somehow that position will be
applauded as not only correct but but
based
so this is how it works as the Overton
window continues its Relentless March to
the left what was a fringe left-wing
view yesterday suddenly becomes
mainstream today and The Fringe today
will be mainstream tomorrow
meanwhile the oblivious faction of
conservatives a rather large group
unfortunately continue to embrace any
position that is not at this moment on
the extreme left-wing Fringe
as long as it's not the most extreme
version of leftism they embrace it
which means that tomorrow they will
Embrace whatever is on the extreme
left-wing Fringe today
Jeffree star's conservative Defenders
have told me that well we should accept
him into the fold because he is they say
mostly right about the gender issue
but he's not mostly right he's not even
in the neighborhood of right
he's he's not in the play he's not I
don't know what planet he's even on let
alone the neighborhood
he believes that a person can identify
as and actually be a member of the
opposite sex he affirms trying to
transgenderism it's just that he prefers
to stick with the term transgender to
describe those people and believes that
non-binary is extra and redundant
and he's right that it is redundant you
know as non-binary versus transgenderism
that is a distinction without a
difference so that doesn't make him more
right or closer to the truth he's not
suddenly a Defender Of Truth and
tradition because he prefers to stick
with the craziest left-wing ideas from
yesterday rather than adopting the
craziest ideas from today
in fact non-binary isn't even really
crazier than transgenderism these terms
are again redundant they are versions of
the same nonsense
star prefers using one term for the
nonsense rather than two this apparently
is enough to make him Our Generations
William F Buckley
the left here is using a classic
manipulation technique you make an
outrageous demand so that a slightly
less outrageous demand seems reasonable
by comparison we should all be familiar
with the strategy it's the oldest one in
the book right kids use it all the time
just a few nights ago my son
came up to me after dinner and said
Daddy can we all go get ice cream
now asking me to load all six kids in
the car after dinner
when I already have my sweatpants and
slippers on definitely qualifies as an
outrageous demand that's one thing they
know
once the slippers come out I'm not going
anywhere that we're we are here for the
night
so I said no and then he immediately
followed it up with okay well then can
we just watch a movie
now in that case I knowingly allowed
myself to be suckered by the strategy
and I let them watch a movie but on a
cultural level in the in the battle with
the left
we cannot be so easily duped by these
kinds of Tricks just because non-binary
is arguably a little weirder weirder
than trans that doesn't make trans
legitimate or any closer to legitimate
than it was before
celebrating Jeffree Star at this point
it's like if somebody was beating you
over the head with a baseball bat and
then Jeffree Star ran in and said no
don't beat him over the head with a
baseball bat just stomp on his face with
your boot instead here I'll help
now it's true that getting stomped is
probably a little better than being
bludgeoned with a bat but does that
automatically make the person stomping
on your face an ally
would you applaud this person as they
kick you in the skull and say wow this
guy's great we should invite him to CPAC
no he's still your enemy he's still
trying to kill you just perhaps in a
slightly less efficient manner
see the curse of the big tent
conservatism approach is that now our
tent is filled with people who are
directly trying to undermine our cause a
big tent doesn't do a lot of good when
you're inviting people under it who will
just try to rip it down and leave all of
us standing in the rain which is what's
happening
one last point on all this
star says that we need someone who looks
like him to say the things that he says
because if we say it that is if normal
people who aren't cross-dressing circus
performers say it then we will be called
bigots and transphobes well except this
logic is refuted by his follow-up video
in which he defends himself against
accusations of bigotry and transphobia
so it turns out that tokenism is not
actually an effective strategy here we
cannot insulate ourselves from criticism
by putting our arguments into the mouths
of people who fall into identity
categories that the left usually
celebrates
okay I don't know how conservatives keep
thinking this strategy will work it
never has it never will
doesn't work
like can you give me an example of
someone who's in one of these identity
groups and they make it conservative
well not even conservative they make a
slightly less less left-wing argument
and the left goes well you know normally
I disagree with that but this person is
an identity group that we support so I
think we'll take into consideration has
that ever happened is there one example
of that working
no it doesn't because the left values
ideological Conformity over all else
their vision of diversity is one in
which people of all Races ethnicities
sexual orientations except white males
and made-up genders come together
to march in lockstep and speak in unison
anybody who misses a beat or forgets a
line or tries to improvise will be cast
out is not only a bigot but a traitor as
well
just as it turns out the people from
protected classes who disagree with the
left
are not given softer treatment or a
better chance at a fair hearing if
anything they're shouted down although
louder and hated all the more
because on top of uh of saying the
things that the left hates there's also
the element of betrayal
because the left says well you're
supposed to belong to us because of your
identity
that doesn't make them that doesn't make
the you know the heretic more credible
in the eyes of the left it just makes
them a heretic
just look at Jeffree Star he agrees with
the left on nearly everything
and he's living exactly the kind of
Lifestyle they promote but they still
Exile him for mildly criticizing one
small facet of gender ideology
well that doesn't make him our Ally or
our friend
but it does prove that this whole you
know you need people like me to make
this argument claim is moot
no we don't need people like him to make
the argument we don't need a
cross-dressing trans activist with neck
tattoos and copious amounts of makeup to
make the argument you know who we need
this goes back to the beginning of the
show we need normal people
normal people like you normal Common
Sense people who live normal lives and
dress and act like normal people we need
them to speak up and be advocates
because after all normalcy is what we're
trying to defend isn't it the best
defender of normalcy is a normal person
and not just one normal person but
Legions of them an army of normal people
demanding a return to sanity and Common
Sense and basic moral decency Jeffree
Star
is not ever going to be an effective
Champion for that cause
but you can be
and that is why Jeffree Star and his
conservative Defenders are today
canceled
that'll do it for this portion of the
shows move over to the members block if
you're not a member yet you can become a
member by using Code wallsha checkout
for two months free on all annual plans
hope to see you over there if not talk
to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]